following the dot-com crash as money
dried up and the company's stock crashed
95
the executives set up an emergency
meeting while their e-commerce business
was still growing rapidly it was far
from being profitable so they decided to
launch a platform that helped other
companies to build their own e-commerce
websites called merchant.com hearing the
story you probably thought that this is
how shopify got started right
well this was actually the story of
amazon and their diversification effort
after the dot-com crash but this wasn't
actually all that successful you see
amazon's rapid growth throughout the
1990s had led to a rather unorganized
business environment which made it
extremely difficult for them to
successfully launch merchant.com so
amazon quickly dropped the idea and
started testing out other paths for
diversification six years later though
in 2006 shopify leveraged the same
business model as merchant.com and they
knocked it out of the park so here's the
story of shopify and how they showed up
amazon at their own game
taking a look back the story of shopify
circles back to a man named tobias ludka
who was born in 1981 in copeland's west
germany his father was an internal
medicine doctor while his mother was a
teacher for disabled children from a
very young age toby had a massive
interest in modifying computer hardware
and coding so when he was six years old
his parents bought him a computer
similar to the commodore 64. and within
the next few years toby taught himself
how to write code and develop simple
games despite this innate curiosity to
experiment and learn by himself it
doesn't seem like toby was a big fan of
school whenever a teacher asked him a
question toby preferred to give them
smart witty responses instead of
actually answering the question and toby
took shortcuts whenever possible and
tried to pass his classes by spending
the least amount of effort possible in
my opinion i think toby simply had his
priorities straight from a very young
age but to his parents and teachers this
was quite concerning so they had toby
take a bunch of psychoanalysis exams to
identify if he had any learning
disabilities but they were never able to
diagnose anything and as toby grew older
his behavior from a traditional
perspective simply got worse and worse
toby says that he had a serious
authority problem and hated answering to
teachers so as soon as he could drop out
of school he did at age 16 from 10th
grade toby went ahead and joined a
computer science apprentice program at
simon's but he didn't like this very
much either you see it the
apprenticeship required him to use java
which he felt was a super restrictive
programming language in this world
filled with restrictions and limitations
toby felt that there was only one true
escape which was snowboarding toby would
regularly go on snowboarding trips and
one of these trips took him to whistler
british columbia where he met a girl
named fiona mckeen as you would guess
these two would fall in love and due to
the great distance between germany and
canada they would have to figure out a
living situation initially they agreed
to live in each other's countries in
alternating years first fiona came to
germany and lived with toby for a year
and then toby moved to canada to live
with fiona for a year but he never came
back
despite finding the love of his life
toby was still kind of a bum at the end
of the day he was still a high school
dropout that had no idea what he wanted
to do so he started networking with
people in canada one of the first people
he ran into was a man named scott lake
scott was a family friend of fiona and
would regularly come to family events
and this is when he would meet toby toby
was significantly younger than scott
coming in at 12 years younger but the
two had several similar interests and
soon enough they decided to start a
business together in 2004. the initial
plan wasn't anything crazy or
revolutionary the duo just wanted to
sell something that they were both
passionate about snowboards through the
internet though the idea was simple they
wanted it to be personal in other words
they didn't just want to flip snowboards
on ebay so they decided to launch their
own e-commerce website but all the
e-commerce software available at the
time was absolute crap according to toby
so toby decided to develop his own as
you might expect with toby though he
refused to use any of the popular
programming languages because he thought
that all of them were too restricting so
instead he used an obscure japanese
programming language called ruby ruby
was so obscure that it didn't even have
written documentation in english luckily
for toby though a danish programmer
named david hansen would develop a new
framework for ruby around the same time
which made it much easier for toby to
code this new framework also generated a
lot of interest within the coding space
regarding ruby which got toby involved
in several online forums relating to
ruby toby shared a lot of his software
on these forums such as his software for
processing credit cards and he quickly
became a leading voice within the
community in the meantime toby and scott
were also packaging up snowboards and
sending them to customers but given all
the interest online surrounding toby
software it became pretty clear to toby
and scott that selling software was the
way to go
despite this grand vision neither toby
nor scott had much money so they started
raising money from their friends and
family they were able to raise a total
of two hundred thousand dollars from ten
people with the biggest investors being
fiona's father bruce mckeen and toby's
uncle fun fact this investment would end
up making bruce a billionaire anyway
using these funds arduous went ahead and
hired a german programmer named daniel
waynon who they considered to be a
co-founder of shopify the name shopify
has actually been around since the start
of the company but the company wasn't
actually originally called shopify the
company was actually called a jaded
pixel and shopify was just the name of
the software given the cloud tobii had
amongst online forms they were rapidly
able to build up a base of customers and
start pulling in monthly revenue of
about eight thousand dollars over the
next two years this number would almost
grow tenfold to sixty thousand dollars
per month but this also forced toby to
raise a lot more money which he didn't
really want to do
it's not that toby didn't want to bring
on investors but rather he didn't want
to bring on venture capitalists who he
thought would ruin the company scott
strongly disagreed with his perspective
and felt that venture capital was the
way to go and given the company's
desperate need for cash toby gave in and
started pitching to vcs but no vc really
wanted to invest in an e-commerce
business they felt like they had already
tried that in the 1990s which resulted
in a dot-com crash and a massive losses
so why would they try that again after
failing to raise more capital scott
would leave the company and the toby
would become the ceo of shopify toby
didn't really want to be ceo though he
just wanted to code great software but
with the future of the company at stake
toby would try to teach himself business
he started meeting with a lot more vcs
but these meetings just exposed how
close he was toby wasn't familiar with
the technical business terminology like
margin ratios so he struggled to answer
these questions when vcs asked him but
toby didn't let this stop him after
every vc meeting toby would learn about
the term that he didn't know which
allowed him to approach the next meeting
with just a bit more knowledge slowly
toby's vc meeting started to get better
and better but then the 2008 financial
recession hit which basically made it
impossible for an e-commerce company to
raise money and with that toby knew that
he was truly on his own
the next two years would end up being
the roughest years of shopify's history
toby and fiona had to live with fiona's
parents and her father had to fund
payroll from his savings toby says that
the situation was extremely demoralizing
every day at meetings toby discussed the
long-term goals and vision of shopify
but the truth was that it wasn't clear
if shopify would even survive the next
few months toby refused to focus on the
short term though he was adamant that
they needed to think long term for the
company to truly be successful and since
he couldn't do too much about the
company's financial situation for the
time being he decided to focus on
building a phenomenal team you would
think that toby was looking for genius
programmers that were willing to go all
in on shopify but this couldn't be
further from the truth toby says that he
would hire a team player over a
brilliant jerk any day of the week also
despite all this hardship toby never
pulled an elon he refused to work 100
hour weeks and he refused to force
employees to do that either toby
strongly believes that with creative
work you can't cheat he says that
everyone only has five creative hours
per day and trying to work for longer
hours doesn't lead to better results
while this strongly goes against all the
beliefs of silicon valley toby stuck
with it even during the worst of times
and as the world is slowly recovered
from the financial recession the
interest in e-commerce started to come
back to life and shopify was finally
able to achieve profitability by 2010.
around the same time vcs became more
open to investing in e-commerce once
again and the bessemer venture partners
would agree to invest 7 million dollars
into shopify for 20 of the company in
december of 2010. the following year
shopify would raise another 15 million
dollars and in 2013 they would raise 100
million dollars toby would top all this
off by taking shopify public in 2015
which value the company added just over
1 billion dollars toby had successfully
navigated the company through the
recession and built a team that was
stronger than ever before but shopify
was yet to even receive their biggest
push
up until this point shopify mainly
appealed to small business owners who
wanted to expand their business through
the internet but in 2017 and 2018 we saw
the rise of one of the most infamous get
rich quick schemes of all time drop
shipping if you're not familiar with the
drop shipping it it's basically the idea
to start an online store using shopify
sourcing products on alibaba or
aliexpress and then linking the two
together this way you don't have to
physically deal with a product and your
job is to just market it while it sounds
simple in theory it's actually extremely
difficult now this isn't to say that you
can't make great money through drop
shipping but like with any business the
vast majority fail and it's not nearly
as easy as the dropshipping gurus make
it out to be nonetheless this explosive
trend towards dropshipping was extremely
lucrative for shopify and sent them to
the moon last year shopify reached a
peak market cap of 212 billion dollars
since then shopify stock has actually
gotten destroyed along with the rest of
the market dropping over 60
this has crumbled shopify's market cap
down to just over 80 billion dollars but
this is really nothing to worry about if
we look at shopify's revenue and the
gross profit graphs they haven't even
had a single negative quarter so i find
it hard to believe that shopify will be
fundamentally struggling anytime soon as
for toby his net worth peaked at over 10
billion dollars but it has since cooled
down to just under 6 billion toby
doesn't really care much about these
numbers though while he is super
passionate about shopify and grateful
that he's able to work on what he loves
he also believed that at the end of the
day shopify is just a job and no job
will ever take priority over his family
or personal health just like at the
beginning it looks like toby still has
his priorities straight what do you guys
think about toby's approach to working
do you agree that humans shouldn't work
past a certain point regardless of the
situation comment that down below
also drop a like if you appreciate toby
being the number one donator to team
trees and of course consider checking
out our international channels to watch
the videos in other languages and
consider subscribing to see more
questions logically answered but until
then i'm mari and i'll see you guys on
the next one
you